joining us now former a CDC director dr.
Tom Frieden doctor where are we with
this virus now are we past the peak and
your predecessor in the job the current
CDC director dr. Robert Redfield tweeted
this on Friday based on 12 different
forecasting models we will see deaths
exceeding 100,000 by June 1 that's just
two weeks from now what do you think
well I said the same thing about two
weeks ago in my testimony in Congress
tragically this is a really bad virus
and we are just at the beginning we're
in different places in different parts
of the country in New York City where I
am today and where I live we are at the
end of the beginning
in some other places of the country it
hasn't yet hit in full force the bottom
line Chris is that the safer we start
the sooner we can reopen our economy we
start safer we reopen sooner you say
we're just at the beginning but people
are already talking about a second wave
either next fall or next winter dr. Rick
Wright who was one of the
administration's top experts on vaccines
who has been moved out of that job and
is now a whistleblower he testified
about the second wave this week take a
look there will be likely a resurgence
of kovat 19 this fall it'll be greatly
compounded by the challenges of seasonal
influenza without better planning 2020
could be the darkest winter in modern
history dr. Frieden is Rick right
correct
no one can predict with certainty what's
going to happen with this virus it's a
new virus we think it may spread a
little bit less in warmer weather that
could help us but I think it's not right
to think of a second wave unfortunately
we're likely to see multiple waves in
different parts of the country we know
that this can spread explosively if it
gets out of control that's why we have
to be so careful we're all tired of
waiting at home we want to get out I
want to get back in the gym we want to
get back to our lives we want to get our
economy back but at the same time if we
go too fast it will backfire and we can
see explosive spread that could bring us
back in fundamentally it's not just the
lockdowns that are keeping us at home
it's the virus the virus is the enemy
here and you know Chris Yogi Berra said
if people don't want to go to the
ballpark how you gonna stop if people
aren't feeling safe going out they're
not gonna go to dine to eat shop to do
other things that's why it's so
important that to get our economy back
soon
we start safe well you say start safe as
we just said 48 states have reopened to
some degree some businesses some parks
and beaches do you think we're moving
too soon to reopen out-of-doors is great
there's a very very low risk of spread
out of doors so by all means go out take
a walk bicycle enjoy nature it's good
for you it's good for your health and
there's some businesses that are
essential and there's some businesses it
can start with minimal risk there are
other things that are going to be harder
to do without without a lot of safety
measures so we're going to see not
shaking hands for a while we're going to
see using hand sanitizer a lot we're
going to see face masks where it's
spreading widely where you're within six
feet of someone especially if you're
indoors there are things that we can do
so that we start this safer doesn't mean
you have to stay home forever doesn't
mean we have to be careful because if
you get the virus it's not just about
you getting sick you could without
feeling sick spread it to your
neighbor's kid who has leukemia and they
could get deathly ill we're all in this
together we're fighting a virus that is
a really difficult enemy to fight and
it's still out there it's going to be
there the more we're safe from this
fight
actually the more will be safe from flu
as well those things we do to physically
distance those are gonna cut down our
flu level as well and if everybody gets
a flu vaccine this fall that'll be
helpful too
just keep in mind this is a lot worse
than the flu this is ten times badly it
spreads much more readily it's more
likely to kill you and we don't have any
immunity naturally and we don't yet have
a vaccine well I want to pick up on this
question of where we are in the virus
and and the question of reopening
because we heard two very different
arguments this week from President Trump
and from dr. Anthony Fauci here they are
there is a real risk that you will
trigger an outbreak as you may not be
able to control look he wants to play
all sides of the equation I want to
point to a specific state because there
was a lot of criticism when Georgia and
its governor Brian Kemp reopened a few
weeks ago and they reopened salons and
gyms even got criticism from President
Trump that he was moving too fast but we
have not seen the kind of spike that was
widely feared with that reopening in
Georgia which raises the question are
some public health experts I'll include
you in a nod are you being too alarmist
about this I don't think you can be too
alarmist about what this virus can do
look at New York City over the past two
months more than 20,000 deaths from this
virus it's really been catastrophic but
it is important to recognize that there
are things we can do to go out more
safely and I have friends in Georgia
still and they describe to me physical
distancing in shops people being very
careful that's important also keep in
mind the virus mutates it changes it
evolves but fundamentally when it begins
to spread again you won't see that for a
few weeks because it takes about a week
to get sick another week to get very
sick and then you make other people sick
so once there is the resumption of
spread you might not see that for a
month or two there's a lag
on Friday as we reported president Trump
announced operation warp speed an effort
to marshal the government private
companies the military to develop a
vaccine and 200 million doses by the end
of this year how realistic is that 200
million doses of they prove safe vaccine
by the end of the year well it is
absolutely the right thing to do to pull
out all the stops to try to make a safe
and effective vaccine and we all hope
will be available as soon as possible
just keep in mind vaccine is complicated
you have to prove it's safe you have to
prove it's effective you have to make
huge quantities you have to figure out
the doses at one dose or two how much of
it you have to figure out who gets it
first healthcare workers would be first
in line and you've got to get it out
there and explain to people what it is
monitor to see if there are adverse
reactions so absolutely a vaccine is the
single most important weapon we could
develop against this virus but we don't
have one yet we hope we will we hope it
will be soon but we cannot count on it
that's why we need to get used to the
fact that the virus is here for a while
we're going to change what we do so that
we can restart our economy and our
society as soon and safely as possible
well I want to pick up on that because
the president said while he's pushing
for a vaccine the country is coming back
regardless
take a look you know it's not solely
vaccine based other things have never
had a vaccine and they go away I just
want to make something clear it's very
important vaccine or no vaccine we're
back can kovat 19 just go away as the
president says and how back to normal
back to normal I understand we can
reopen some but how back to normal can
we get without a vaccine
it's unlikely that the VAT that the
virus would simply disappear that would
be unusual based on what we've seen in
200 countries around the world but we
don't know how it'll behave over the
summer we don't know how long it will
persist and what will happen with it no
one can predict with certainty but one
thing that is highly likely is that we
will be coming to a new normal things
will be different we won't be shaking
hands for a while we'll be using lots of
hand sanitizer will be safe whenever we
can be our health care system needs to
get a lot safer
not just for kovat but for other
infections as well we'll be traveling
less we're going to see challenges with
different countries not letting people
in or having quarantines and we're
likely to continue to have outbreaks in
places like nursing homes which are as I
said more than two months ago ground
zero for this we're going to see
unfortunately thousands of deaths but we
can save a lot of lives if we focus on
being in this together there is only one
enemy here Chris it's the virus we're
all in it together and the more we're
safe the more we work together it's not
about economy versus health if people
are poor they're less likely to be
healthy and unless we control the virus
we're not going to get our economy back
so we're in it together
again Chris dr. Frieden I got about a
minute left and I got a final question
as far back as I can remember the CDC
has always been the lead agency in
health crises like this I remember when
you were there and there were various
pandemics a bowl of things like that I
would be talking to you as the lead
person for the CDC and the lead person
for the administration this time it
seems like the CDC has been sidelined to
some degree they have not had a public
briefing in more than two months one do
you agree that the CDC that its role has
been diminished and do you think that is
reasonable or do you think that's a
mistake I will personally feel safer
when CDC is speaking regularly to the
American people they are the world's
experts in this no other doctor no other
agency in the US government has the
depth and breadth of expertise of CDC
they continue to do great work and in
fact
Americans are voting with their clicks
there have been more than 1.2 billion
clicks on the CDC website and it's still
the best place to go for objective
information advice recommendations on
how to protect yourself your family your
community so I hope we'll be hearing
though very late so Bradley do you think
it's been a mistake for this
administration to sideline the CDC
I think fighting this pandemic without
the CDC is like fighting with one arm
tied behind your back
that's brief and direct dr. Frieden
thank you thanks for your time always
good to talk with you sir and please
stay safe